-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
The Senate yesterday passed
the trillion-dollar
bipartisan infrastructure bill.
It's what Chris Cuomo is calling
absolutely the only news
right now.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, the Senate
yesterday passed
the trillion-dollar
bipartisan infrastructure bill
and 19 Republican Senators voted
for the legislation,
including Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell,
which means that --
Oh, no.
Oh, what's wrong with it?
What did we do?!
[ Laughter ]
When asked, during a press
conference yesterday,
to assess New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo's
time in office,
President Biden said,
"He's done a hell of a job."
No offense, but I don't think
that's what they
were asking about.
If someone asks your opinion
on what OJ Simpson did,
they don't mean
with the Buffalo Bills.
[ Laughter ]
Former Education Secretary
Betsy DeVos announced yesterday
she will not run for governor
of Michigan next year.
Well, actually,
she said president of Michigan,
but you get the idea.
The state of Oregon
today restored
its statewide mask mandate,
after receiving
this dire warning.
[ Laughter ]
A driver in Staten Island
this weekend crashed
into the front
of a Dunkin' Donuts.
Oh, man, that was like
their one nice restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, Colin.
Sorry, Pete.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, Pepsi announced
a new partnership yesterday
with the brewers
of Sam Adams beer
to create an alcoholic version
of Mountain Dew
and, if that sounds good to you,
don't worry about what's
in the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.